the other thing is we don't have to be
polite we don't have to be polite
I remember expertly in the 60s the first
time I mean I was a wide-eyed freshman
and I took a big survey course in
anthropology that had people of all you
know freshman sophomores juniors and
seniors in this class and there we were
and this professor some gray beard did
great hoary with wisdom was holding for
and somebody stood up and said [ __ ]
and you could just hear a pin drop and
then somebody else stood up and said yes
this is [ __ ] and it's like the
Emperor's and enclose the whole thing
begins to unravel because so much BS is
being slung so and you know it's hard to
know where to draw the line but I think
we need to be very very critical of our
institutions I hate this whole Clinton
thing because I don't like people who
walk around assured that now the world
is safe and I blast the fort terminer of
Arkansas has taken right now we need
worry no more and people my god do you
know what you have to be to be the
four-time governor of Arkansas what a
blood-soaked the gangster creep you have
to be to ascend through that you know
what you would be like if you live in
governor of Arkansas four terms can you
in wrap your mind around the concept and
there this is the little ho this is this
is the good some clown trying to stumble
through but if this is people's idea of
radical social reform if this is
people's idea of putting a place imagine
we need to limit the Earth's population
back down male birds legalize
psychedelics get rid of atomic weapons
move to a hydrogen economy so forth and
so on and when they suggest closing an
air of an airbase near Sacramento the
California papers are full of articles
about whether Western civilization can
survive the Shockers yeah
my friends I mean there are shocks on
the way that will make clothes in an
airbase not even register on the meter